good morning Hank it's Wednesday so
sarin I know the tunes too a lot of well
applies but we don't know the words to
any of those lullabies which has
necessitated us coming up with our own
lyrics no where is this phenomenon
weirder than in the list of things that
Daddy is going to buy Henry in the event
that the Mockingbird doesn't sing hush
little baby don't say a word
daddy's gonna buy you a mockingbird and
if that Mockingbird don't sing daddy's
gonna buy you with diamond ring and if
that diamond ring don't shine well
daddy's gonna buy you a case of wine and
if because you're an infant and not
allowed to drink that wine should go
sour daddy's gonna buy you a superpower
and if that superpower proves corrupt
and daddy's gonna buy a volcano erupt in
and if that eruption produces too much
ash daddy's gonna buy you a diaper rash
and if that diaper rash actually isn't
desirable and besides that can't be
bought well dad is gonna buy you some
polka dots polka dots and if those polka
dots aren't your style daddy's gonna buy
a Pacific aisle and if that Pacific Isle
is in fact way too expensive for daddy
to purchase and he defaults on his loan
and gets foreclosed upon dad is gonna
buy you the Sultanate of Oman and if
given that daddy could not afford a tiny
island his promise to buy you a
sovereign nation is plainly silly
daddy's gonna buy you some water lilies
and if those water lilies ever should
wilt daddy's gonna buy you a
and knit quilt and if after all that you
still weep daddy's gonna have to grapple
with the fact that while buying goods
and services may benefit the economy
it's not necessarily the best way to get
babies to sleep dumb Oh Hank I'll see
you on Friday
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do da da